let's see er this is actually your first
english-language movie isn't ER and
you're working with Keira Knightley and
Jo right how has it been I mean it's
amazing just being here finally seeing
that people are gonna see this film
tonight and yes to will be where this
problem passed and for Jo to be my first
English director throughout but I
couldn't be more thrilled and excited
about it now I know that you took many
years training as a ballet dancer didn't
you and that came to be quite beneficial
for this film didn't it tell me about
that
well when he told we were going to do
all of those movements in the film I was
thrilled because I when I quit I just
didn't want to accept my foot in a
studio but this is a nice way of you
know kind of combining the two and it's
not just the actual dance choreography
is it is how you move as well tell me
about how it changes in the whole film I
mean I think the thought was in the end
that people are not going to think of it
as a choreography but most of the scenes
are very much thought into and a lot of
weeks training and it's not your first
period drama or your costume drama
either is it because of course you had
came up a royal affair before I started
this shoot and
so I was you know I had trained wearing
all the corsets
I had already fainted a couple of times
did you faint at all an accreditor I
didn't I suddenly knew asked what I
couldn't and couldn't do I guess
and how did you find the costumes they
were quite beautiful aren't they
I mean she's made some piece of art
every week I came to my dressing room
and she had new dresses she made all of
the dresses along the way so there's a
girl's dream I'm working with general
Gleason as well how was that I mean it
was just such a fun thing we met a year
before theme the shooting star awarded
at the Berlin Film Festival and we
actually were paired up having press and
I said yeah I mean we've I would love to
work with DOMA I've seen his films just
a great actor and then a few months
later was standing on set doing this
film and Joe had no idea we knew each
other but he's a brilliant actor and he
could another english-language film
coming up after this haven't you tell me
a little bit about that
yes it's called seventh son that's
something completely different
still very epic but it's a fantasy
adventure of foam and I play a
half-witch half-human yeah
olivia williams is in that as well isn't
she we were talking about it in the
makeup trailer because we still don't
have any scenes together now I we've
done two films where we haven't been on
set next time maybe thanks so much for
speaking to siliceous have a good night
you